tu as ma carte pendant une heure si toi
aussi tu n'aimes pas d'idées s'est
renseigné quoi ferrari fait une nocturne
ice et laurence ferrari tu fais mieux
son attachement aux quelque chose tu es
vraiment honnête oui m'a dit t'es
vraiment très honnête mais vas-y ac le
coeur pur luxe note vraiment pour de
vrai si tu veux vraiment je me barre une
demi-heure vraiment juste une demi heure
mais tu sais ce qu'on fait je prends ta
carte
j'aurais intermarché j'ai fait plein de
de bouffe c'est pas pour nous c'est pour
les gens pour rien ça va ou pas alors on
fait un truc moi je te jure j'ai ce
qu'il faut dans la vie non tu sais ce
que tu fais voilà ce qu'on va faire un
jeu on va on va organiser un jeu et une
ferrari ce qu'on peut aller ya un
supermarché juste dehors tu as deux
minutes pour acheter le maximum de ceux
qui ont brillé dans le supermarché
une fois que tu es dans une super manche
et aura deux minutes pour prendre n'est
pas de ce qui est produit nécessite et
tu veux tout ce que tu veux mais je sais
course associé avec une envolée des deux
canons vous avez tous bouffés vous db5
avec deux caddies sinon si les gens
attendaient à nantes 2 2 minutes n'a pas
tu as plus gourmand que tu prends ce que
tu veux d'accord c'est comme ça que je
ne me retire dans ces trois cas d'accord
tu prends 20 20 média qui a l'air sympa
à guesnain les monocoques quoi va partir
dans deux minutes
d'accord le code inquiète le code est
cela ne plaît pas entendu la cause est
ce que tu as le code à quatre chiffres
le code de quatre chiffres
il change la vie le code aux nombreuses
fautes qui peuvent avoir un lien avec
vous et je vais prendre la personne ou
vraiment je prends la meilleure personne
pour venir et vous vous
on va muscler
vous avez deux minutes rayon alcool
écoute renaître avec concert au prolé
ans on donnera bien sûr tout ça bush
voilà dans le magasin je suis bas à
gauche et les concernent voilà c'est
tout naturellement qu'il faut prendre
plein de son père c'est william saurin
conserve des pâtes des couches
attention vous avez deux minutes pas une
minute et pas une seconde de plus mais
une fois dans le magasin je vais donner
la carte abattue devant mot doc
tu te sens capable d'y aller avec lui
bien sûr est-ce que tu alors maintenant
c'est une mémoire de mémoire des sons va
vous le donnez vous le donnez code
déborder les chocottes alors on va se
retrouver dans un instant on trouvera un
matthieu delormeau et doc gynéco avec ma
carte vous achèterez ce que vous voudrez
pendant deux minutes
d'accord vous reviendrez avec les
victuailles d'accord on fera un point
est ce que vous êtes content ball
coéquipier chez nana question oui s'il
ya une 55 juste en face il ya bmw est ce
que je fais un cinquième on ne pourrait
pas acheter trop beau et ça passera
passera pas ça passera pas on est en
train de faire opposition
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces 24h sur 24 doc gynéco matthieu
delormeau vous partez en mission non pas
pour nous mais pour la france
ouais allez quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya vous
allez avoir sa tension est passé quelque
chose donc on a fait le 4e le carte
bleue challenge le cb challenge le cbc
et matthieu delormeau a réussi à arrêter
une marée bleue boom avec son front mais
c'est fou on la condamne d'argent les
neuf voix à droite on aime l'argent même
la relance et prévert et donc il s'est
mis d'accord avec lui et il va partir
dans un supermarché
il va acheter pendant deux minutes tout
ce qu'il veut et on offrira ça moi je
dis il faut faire ça à une personne qui
nous regardent adrian hashtag tpm peut
on pas dire cbh tac tpm pcb vous vous
inscrivez et dans un instant vous
donnera le nom du ou de la gagnante
qui va gagner tous que matthieu
delormeau va acheter alors attention il
n'est pas seul il n'est pas seul car on
lui a mis on lui a mis un handicap et on
est amer un handicap il est avec doc
gynéco attention on va lancer le chrono
vous avez vous avez deux minutes pour
prendre ce que vous voulez dire qu'il
n'a pas tant s'en faut - ouais bravo oui
ou alors attention il faut qu'ils
puissent ramener tout ici sinon c'est
pas valider un accord
il aura ensuite une minute pour tours
année d'accord il fait 120 minutes dans
le supermarché et une minute pour
tourner elle s'il ramène tout ici donc
dans trois minutes ce sera gagné
attention à nier vous et près de 2
j'entends
gillet
oui
[Musique]
al wahda
m
[Musique]
allez soyons plus qu'une minute cas ce
parti on sait pas et colmar venait
passer quand ce n'était pas prévu qu'est
ce qui se passe le cadreur il est malade
ou quoi est-ce que vous avez déjà vu un
cadreur filmer la route frère chez nous
il ya cru ça arrive allez allez allez
allez on y va allez allez allez on y va
on fait la relève arrive en silence en
retard alors être comparables ont
démontré allez allez au matelas plus
qu'à retrouver mathieu de la loi veil
avocat
mais qu'est-ce qui fait il encore aller
si le monde allait d'un corps 45 ans ils
n'ont pas cherché de match assez de
trucs et là il a acheté trois trucs et
qu'il écoute qu'il écoute et regarde à
kiel et qu'on l'a laissé ma carcasse
comme ça
[Musique]
c'est terminé s'est terminée la parade
en l'instant tout ce qui doit jeter une
fois qu'ils seront pas sans kate on va
refaire un point sur les séries et ils
ont une minute pour tourner s'ils
ramènent tout au bout d'une minute
la personne qui est en train d'inscrire
hashtag tpm pcb et bâle gagnera tout ce
qu'ils ont acheté comme quoi je sais pas
du tout ce qui nous achetions va tout
découvrir
armand d'urmatt ou découvrir dans un
instant ils ont acheté du riz je pense
que la doc gynéco et parcs et aux
boissons son plaisir personnel a aidé à
bâtir le voilà alors attention avant de
les retrouver
le temps qu'ils payent et cetera nous
arrive un truc on est vraiment la télé
de la roumanie on va affiner votre
conseil de classe mais juste avant on
vient de me dire dans l'oreillette
il ne reste presque plus de batterie
dans la caméra minutes pour année toutes
leurs courses attention
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
les allées
savons pas tout
ça
[Musique]
alors
on allait
ça c'est bon pas bon
c'est pas la danse gym et coiffure et
paris
défauts qui a la cote
la vérité
valet
à lévis
[Musique]
voilà
ces deux dernières
[Applaudissements]
l'aja
alors l'échelle doc gynéco voilà baïla
pizza pas réussi des filles heureusement
alors on va prendre tout l'été sussac et
perso pour moi ne m'intéresse c'est quoi
c'est quoi qu'est ce qu'il a acheté tout
pour le petit déj vertus qu'on va se
marrer oui mais si j'ai bonne soirée non
mais non mais si vous écoutez on voit
bien qu'il est au régime
ouais c'est demain matin perdu sans quoi
la wii va donc on le voit plus
alors voilà attendez regarder matthieu
delormeau on va voir ce qu'ils ont
ramené il a amené beaucoup de riz c'est
bien c'est beaucoup beaucoup de riz on
aura également du riz mais vous avez
mais il a ramené du risque en l2 et
qu'il est con il arrive à tuer du riz à
y aller il ya des friandises très bien
il ya du talent tu cette fois les modes
tous sont égaux ya des albums se sont
vendus rappelait tous conservent une
demi-heure après le défi des côtes
[Applaudissements]
choses aller avec moi je prend les
cadeaux on vous donnera le nom du
gagnant ou de la gagnante dans un
instant et bravo à matthieu delormeau
aux torrents d'eau les unes qui a gagné
et gwendoline il repart et toute cette
course va nous libérer
on va mettre tout ça dans ferait bien
entendu dans un instant s'il ya besoin
d'être mis au frais